hi my name is Steve Lee I'm the head of
the school
professor there since 1981 and I've been
in architectural practice for over 40
years now today's presentation I think
is very timely the title of it is what
does it take to make your building green
I find in my architectural career that a
more typical question that I get asked
is why should we make our buildings
green I think it's time for a complete
paradigm shift as you see from this
image representing suburban sprawl we're
taking our youngest children and
convincing them that they need an
automobile to get around to do the
things in their daily life in a
neighborhood that's solely homes there
are no businesses there are no schools
there are no shops in that particular
neighborhood and most importantly there
are absolutely no sidewalks that someone
could actually if they chose to walk
would be able to walk let me give you a
few statistics from the Environmental
Protection Agency we have almost a
hundred and twenty eight million
residential units in the United States
we have almost 5 million square feet of
office buildings in the United States
and buildings together account for 40%
of the total energy consumption in the
United States as well as 40% of the
total greenhouse gas emissions in the
United States
in addition buildings account for over
70% of the electricity that we use today
more importantly from the human
perspective we spend over 90% of our
time indoors so the quality of a
building that we occupy is extremely
important to our health another big
issue as we see the drought that's been
happening this summer is the amount of
water that we use buildings consume 13%
of the total water used in the United
States in 50 years the population in the
United States has doubled but our water
demand has tripled of the 26 million
gallons of water that we use in the
United States about 30 percent of that
is used for
outdoor irrigation and landscaping we
spend four billion dollars every year to
keep our water clean and to run our
wastewater utilities another big issue
is the amount of impervious surfaces
that we've introduced into the United
States if you look at the total area of
impervious surfaces in the United States
it would cover an area seventy five
percent of the state of Ohio we generate
250 million tons of municipal waste that
works out to four point six pounds per
person plus we recycle about 1.5 pounds
per person every day and then the
building industry itself in terms of
building and renovating existing and new
buildings produces a hundred and sixty
million tons of waste every year so what
does it take to make your building green
there are really three steps in my mind
to do this the first step is to make
your building zero net energy this means
that the amount of energy generated on
site is equal to the amount of energy
that you consume from the grid whether
it's the electric grid or the natural
gas grid the second important step is
zero carbon this is difficult to attain
the amount of embodied energy and carbon
that is produced in making and
transporting the products to the
building site need to be offset by the
purchase of renewable energy credits so
that you zero out the amount of carbon
related to construction activities but
then once you start operating the
building you have to account for the
carbon that's produced by the operating
of that building typically from fossil
fuels the third step is to make your
building zero water the most aggressive
standard out there for achieving zero
water is from the Living Building
Challenge where they state that a
hundred percent of the buildings project
water needs must be supplied by captured
precipitation
or other natural closed-loop systems and
that you need to account for all of the
downstream impacts of that water that's
used on the site so let's go through
each of those energy carbon and water
sequentially and talk about some
strategies for you to make your building
green here's a great image from the
Lawrence Livermore National Laboratory
that describes the amount of energy
generated that's on the left-hand side
of the drawing and the amount of energy
that is utilized by different category
on the right-hand side of the drawing if
you look at the top two pink boxes we
use about 20% of the total energy for
residential and commercial buildings the
bottom pink box represents
transportation and that's about 30
percent of our energy use so what that
really means is that 50 percent of the
energy consumed in the United States is
directly related to the decisions we
make about where we want to live and
where we want to work the gray bars that
you see here are all waste energy and
it's important to note that of 60
percent of the energy that's put into
this immense system of it's important to
note that 60 percent of the energy
that's input into the system is actually
rejected as waste heat so the first step
in achieving zero net energy is to
reduce energy consumption in the next
five slides I'll show you some quick
strategies the first is with regard to
where we decide to live and work I
believe it's important to work in
mixed-use walkable places to have a high
quality of life but also reduce the
amount of energy just based on the
decision that we make with where we live
the second is to take advantage of the
free energy that's available to us in
this case the Sun and the air and design
buildings such that they respond to the
movement of the Sun and the direction of
the wind I'm using slides here from the
new FIP
Center for sustainable landscapes to
illustrate a zero net building in all
aspects of that and in this image you
see an example of selectively tinted
glass that filters out heat but admits
daylight you see examples of light
shelves to bounce light deep into the
building but prevent that light from
producing glare along the perimeter
where people are working and a really
novel idea
we actually have windows that open in
this building so that you can naturally
ventilate the building when the
conditions are good with regard to the
actual construction involved I can't
overemphasize the importance of
insulating your building here's an
example from the renovation of my office
done three years ago where we used a
spray foam material to not only provide
double the insulation required by the
code but to make a very very tightly
sealed building to prevent heat loss
from air leakage the next step is to
utilize high-efficiency equipment this
is an illustration of a product that was
designed by a graduate from Carnegie
Mellon school a design called the nest
thermostat it's an intelligent
thermostat that records your degree of
satisfaction with the space and develops
patterns and schedules of your usage of
that building to set the thermostat to
control at the most energy efficient
position but in addition it's connected
to the Internet so you can log your
energy performance as well as control
the temperature in your house from your
mobile device there's a lot of energy
efficient equipment out there for new
lighting systems compact fluorescents or
LEDs high-efficiency heating systems
high-efficiency cooling systems energy
recovery devices and high efficiency
appliances it's difficult for a consumer
to know exactly what to choose but a
really good starting place is the Energy
Star program run by the federal
Department of Energy they have great
lists of
products that meet the industry star
qualification so these steps orienting
the building properly taking advantage
of natural conditioning insulating and
air sealing and using high-efficiency
equipment we've brought the load on the
building the energy load on the building
down to the lowest possible level then
and only then can we think about
incorporating renewables in this image
of the Sun the air all of these sources
are in scale the big yellow ball of
course is the Sun the round Brown object
at about 8 o'clock is the total amount
of energy that's used in the United
States in the world on an annual basis
and in this particular case the amount
of energy from the Sun is 1,500 times as
much as the total energy consumption on
the planet it's important that we begin
tapping into this vital resource to move
to the future so we can relieve
ourselves of our addiction to fossil
fuels the image here this is also from
the FIPS CSL project they've installed a
massive photovoltaic array to offset the
electrical loads in the building to
bring it down to meet that zero net
energy definition that I described
earlier there's a important rule of
thumb that if you spend $1 on energy
efficiency strategies within your
building it's roughly equivalent to $10
in purchasing for renewable energy so
it's critically important that everyone
would first insulate and reduce the load
in the building before investing in
renewable energy so that takes care of
the energy strategies the carbon
strategies go hand-in-hand because so
much of our energy use in the United
States is derived from fossil fuels so
for every watt of energy produced by
fossil fuels were pumping a lot of
carbon dioxide into the atmosphere I use
this diagram to illustrate the
city of our carbon system in the in the
world on the planet with energy a carbon
being absorbed and released from the
oceans carbon being sequestered deeply
into the coldest areas of the ocean as
well as deep within the ground
the net result of looking at all of
these balances that have existed in the
world for eleven thousand years we are
now at a state where we're putting in
nine gigatonnes of carbon above the
ability of the Earth's capacity to
absorb that carbon on an annual basis so
it's absolutely critical that we begin
now addressing the issues of emissions
so if you've reduced the energy
consumption of your building if you put
on photovoltaics or solar thermal to
generate energy on-site that's the first
and major step in achieving a zero
carbon building but remember that in our
current electrical grid that one watt of
electricity that's being read on your
meter is actually the result of
producing three watts of energy at the
electrical plant based on the efficiency
of the power plant and the efficiency of
our distribution grid so to achieve zero
emissions for the building you can't
just equal the amount of energy in is
equal to the amount of energy out you
actually have to multiply that by a
factor of three times so this becomes a
big challenge for building owners the
third step is zero water again I
mentioned the Living Building Challenge
is the most aggressive standard that's
out there they require that a hundred
percent of the stormwater and use
project water discharge must be managed
on-site to feed the project's internal
water demands are released into adjacent
ecological areas so in this image from
Phipps CSL you can see the beautiful
integration of the water collection
cistern at the base of a heavily
landscape slope adjacent to the building
so between the lagoon that they've
created here and the underground cistern
that's out of the view of this
particular
image they are managing a hundred
percent of their project water needs and
a hundred percent of the storm water
that falls on to the site so to make a
green building focus on achieving the
goal of zero energy zero carbon and zero
water thank you